Hello everybody! My name is Markiplier and
welcome back to SCP Containment Breach.
So I seem to have regained my composure a little bit since the last episode,
which was a "little" bit scary for me.
And I believe that, uh...
...Yeah, I'm in the clear.
I have got no SCPs on my tail for the first time in ages, so...
...we're going to try--
Noohh, could we get through here?
*Alarm*
[Alarmed Markiplier]
All righty then...yeah, we can.
Oh, no..
[A bunch of alarms and scared Markiplier noises]
Ohhh, no we can't.
Oh, that's right.
This is one o' the closed-off ones.
It's locked with a code that even if I did that, I don't think it would be anywhere.
So...
[Over the alarm]: Let's head back!
Let's head back.
I--even though I hear the sounds of Billy everywhere.
I know that these next two are gonna be absolutely nothing.
Man, hopefully, I can find a save point.
Yes, I can.
[Mark Ughs]
Ugh!
Fuck.
'Cause I didn't save after I got out of that basement
in the last episode and I am not touching that thing for all my life.
Not again.
Uh, Man I Can't Believe
I can't believe this 'poor'
I can't believe this 'poor' D- Class
"Probably" a Murderer Personnel
Which is like, if you ever thought about it...
Thats who this character is
He's someone who's sentenced to a life sentence
and then ah...
brought in to the program for...
experimentation.
[Emotionally distraught]- Cruel and unusual punishment indeed.
[Sounds of disgust]
Not going in that elevator!
I don't think it would work anyway.
*heavy breathing in game*
So...!
This is the way through...
and its got to be somewhere
in the heavy containment zone.
It just has to be.
*Alarm*
I just have to be thorough about it
which means im going to be doing a clean sweep
while I "got-alot-o-demons" on my tail
[mumbling while alarms sound]
Just slow-ley and sure-ley
we dont have 'Radical Larry' on our tail this time
So I think that we have a little more time
than we have
in the past.
And this is actually...
aaaahhhhh...
So what happens if I take the left route and go all the way around?
Even though I know!
Fuckin' Bill-Billy
Bill Belichick is somewhere over here....
NO! Im not going to "Bing Bong" that God-Damned bell again.
Where ya at Billy?!?
Where ya at?
[Markilpier sounds]
So I don't have a direct plan
With which to do all this
But
I've got a pretty decent idea of what I need to do.
If I find one of the Tesla gates,
Which I think was blocking off my pattern before.
I might be able to find my way through it.
THIS time around...
Just gotta keep pressing forward
Ohho! It is! Yeah!
Okay!
Yeah! This was a Tesla gate that, I think...
Ohh, hi?
OH, GOD! That scared the piss out of me!
*loud static*
'Cause that's the -uh-
That's the suit that I left behind!
I fucking left it standing there because- *laughs*
I just was like,
*mocking tone* "Ahh, whatever! I won't need that there!"
So I think I can drop...
Uhh- This key-card 'cause I don't need it.
I just be- You just put that on!
You just generally put it on!
Ohh, fuck...
Hi!
WHY?
*Inhuman Mark noise*
Okay.
So I think- Yeah!
This was the -uh-
This one of the earliest SCPs
And it's some sort of -like-
Virus that's REAL BAD.
Fuck
I knew this suit was gonna scare me!
Oh, fuck
But there's a way to get in here
I'm pretty sure I need to-
Is it something about this?
Oh, yeah!
OH, SHIT!
Oh, okay! It's fine. It's cycled.
Alright. So something in HERE-
There's a reason!
There's a reason for THIS!
There's something in there...
Ahh...
I don't have much to give up...
Uhh...
I'll drop it for now!
But I don't like it!
*Ear-wrenching screech*
[Screams of fear insue]
Whhh- *voice cracks* -aaat!
(It appears Billy Could break through the window)
*shook voice* How were you IN THERE?!
The door was LOCKED!!
OKAAAY!
I GUESS?!
ALRIGHT!
I'll make my way back NOW!...
[Mark groans]
So, I don't see a Billy anywhere!
I don't know how a Billy could get IN here,
fuuucking hel- okay hi
Well- woah, I don't like that at all.
ookay, so whatever. it's fine,
causee this is at a- this is okay.
Whatever it is, it's okayy
Just gonna drop this preemptively, blink before I go.
Grab it and then i'm out.
I'm out-y. I'm fucking out-y.
Oh fuck, hi. WHY?
*quietly* Okay, okay.
*noises* Okay, I closed it, I closed it!
*yelling in fear* Okay. Somehow, someway
Ooooh fuck you Billy Billy.
Fuck you Billy Billy. (x2)
Fuck you, fuck you!
Okay, can he get me in heRE?
*whispers* fuck
Okay! Now I can get in here!
Ooooh fuck me.
Fuck me, lemme save. Please.
Just let me save. UGHHH. Fu-
*loud banging in game* FUUUU-HEY.
*reading* Unknown client, please state your identity
and reason to the denial in case this message goes through,
evacuating 008's security room
incineration and irradiation systems malfunctional
apparently disabled by an unknown client.
Do not enter 008's chamber before it has been
concern- confirmed safe.
WELL. Too late for me now.
Fuck, i'm just gonna leave this riight here.
Aaah, that's comforting. Okay.
So what is the deal with this?
*quietly* fuck.
Okay, uh,
*reading* extreme biological hazards and all related protocols apply.
Incineration and irradiation measures will be deployed in the event of political or military actions.
*breathes in deeply*
What?
*continues reading* -complex prion, samples of which are stored
in the G2 sites, traits of the 008 prion include 100% infectiousness,
100% lethality, transmission through exposed mucus membranes, and all bodily fluids.
Flu-like symptoms, 20 hours after first symptoms-
dementia, coma onset will be considered onset of death.
Red blood cells greatly increase storage capacity,
*skipping around while reading* resulting in slower blood flow,
nervous systems unaffected, total organ failure for several hours,
metabolism- Subject will attempt to ingest living humans!
ooohhhh, subject can adapt to it's damaged nervous system,
but is limited to basic physical activities,
inclusing standing up, balancing on two legs, walking,
biting, grabbing, and crawling.
Riight, subject will attempt to ingest living humans  if physical contact is made.
500- SCP500 has been found to completley cure SCP 008 even in the advanced stages of the disease.
So that is,
that's the zombie virus, is what that is.
but that is...
But why...
Gawd, why did i need to come on here
Why are you so FUCKING terrifying...?
Jesus.....
okay
So I didn't NEED to go in here...
....and 173 is APPARENTLY not here....
*door beeps*
..so I..I GUEEEESS I'm..... fine, then...
I'm gonna go grab my...my medkit again
JUst in case
*Mark Noise*
Ohh
I don't like those sounds
Ho boy
HO BOy
ho boy . OKAY
Now it's time for more of a
clean sweep
WITHOUT BILLY ON MAH NECK
*Mark Noise* Ohh?
O- ohhh
OH Was it-? was it in here
I don't think he's in here anymore.? No  he's not
He's not in here
Which means that I can actually be throughall about this and
Look where I'm going maybe there was a door control-!
*startled Mark*
Maybe there was  a door control in here
Maybe? *sigh of disappointment*
Nah nah nah nah nah
That wasn't it *More Mark sounds*
Fuck
Okay That wasn't it
Definitely wasn't it
IT'S okay though
Cause frankly
That's good. That means I wasn't  an
Idiot last time
Uh Oh..
(Oh hey I can see him :D)
*Loud noise that signifies you're Fucked*  WHAT?! NO! OH COME ON!
OOHNo
Oh Boy..
Ohh Fuck I'm dead
No.. you guys you don't understand
I'm already dead
It doesn't matter
What I do now. Right?
*step*
AHOAHHG OH GOD
*Sounds of death*
Ohh my god! Ohhh My god
Oh my god
* Screaming*
*sigh* OKay
Now we're back alive
Which is great I guess
Okay SO. Word to the wise
The- They- THiy
They've made that even more terrifying
Then they have in the past and I don-
I don- I don't like that at all
I forgot to get my medkit but that's okay
I'm just gonna keep my head down
You Know. Just in case
I don't like any of this
But you know
best in- Ohh fuck
ohhh
ohhhh! ya
that's that's fun that's fun  that's fun
that's that's that's what fun that's fun
oh that's fun oh
oh hey it's this guy again
good
oh fun my friend
oh I'm so surrounded by fun friends
friends with fun funs
fuck
I don't know if i was ever
able to get in there because I think they
they closed off everything right?
they did that thing
I still gotta deal with 096
Oh boy, okay
Here we go again!
Looking at the ground, looking at the really interesting ground
walking backwards
oh my gawd
Oh my gawd!
*laughs* This is horrifying
a- HEyyy
Ohh my god
Okay. He's behind me..
He's behind mEE
Ohh my god!
Entrance zone?
*loud screechy noise*
Ohh!
What?
*another screechy noise*
*noise of a little girl*
Ohhhh, where am I?!
*peculiar trapdoor opening and closing noises*
HoOoOH
Oh this is where I find
a Cp420 Jayyyy?
*beep*
Ohh
Yup it sho- ohh hEy.
You moved.
You moved, I saw that, you moved.
Okay.
Get one of these..
Ah, that's some good shit
*music plays* Ah hell ya
Okay *laughs*
There we go, now
Why is.. Why is everything moving here!?
In this room?
Well a little weird
*music begins to stop*
Oh boy
There's a-
Radio transceiver
Well I think it's out of batteries
Uhh, and I don't have
any batteries left to grab
And this computer is unpowered now (That's not a word Mark)
Which I remembered before it wasn't!
God. I can't even save on any of these!
I just had to give myself
ave restriction!
Okay
But anyway!
Ugh
I'm gonna end this episode here
f**k..
*loud and unexpected noise*
f**king God dammit!
Okay.
Alright.
*Breathes* I'm gonna end this episode here
more last time
I gotta move on
Hope I can get back to this soon
So thank you everybody so much for watching!
Lemme know wh- *laughs*
You think of
how I'm doing in the comments down below..
And as always,
I will see you..
in the next video
Ba-Bye!